the EMG GTR sees Mercedes launching a
street-legal version of its Nurburgring
North Loop winner the gt3 the flagship
model has even been given a paint job of
it's very own
a striking shade called green hell magno
reserved exclusively for the GTR Kasturi
mano L Schaefer says it's to the
racetrack born like all AMG GTS but the
GTR is still a standout with 430
kilowatts or 585 horsepower
only a racetrack can do it justice today
he's in luck tt M winner Ben Schneider
is going to take it for a spin
the booster bag circuit features 4.2
kilometres 19 turns and a 26% downward
gradient this is where they'll put the
AMG through its paces
ban says what distinguishes the gt-r
from its cousins on the street is that
it's another big matchup in terms of
sportiness and right at home on the
track but it also feels right at home on
ordinary streets and is fun to drive
still the racetrack is where you can
push the GTR to its limits which is
great fun it reminds him of his days on
the DTM this car is just as precise as
anything you'd see on the DTM mediatek
water under the hood the GTR takes its
power from a new 4 liter twin-turbo v8
which cranks out 430 kilowatts
it makes the sprint from 0 to 100 km/h
in just 3.6 seconds top speed is 300 18
kilometers per hour manufacturer ratings
put fuel consumption at eleven point
four liters per 100 kilometers but all
this power comes at a price in Germany
that gt-r starts in some 166 thousand
euros
GTR comes equipped with all the systems
that you'd expect in a modern car that
says from electronic stability and
traction control to anti-lock brakes
they can all be controlled individually
from the concrete traction control can
be set to match road conditions from
rain to dry roads or somewhere in
between new tires or older ones knowing
I've been coming as individual person
you can set esc to on mode right now in
what conditions bear prefers on mode
which is perfectly calibrated to these
conditions when it's dry he likes the
sport mode which is good on the
racetrack
who knows all these possible beasts
although on passing to the wrench neck
is mechana tempo first a shock absorbers
are also electronically adjustable on
some race tracks most drivers say you
should take them in sport plus mode and
adjust the shock absorbers to the track
but that does vary a bit if you're on a
track or road that's a bit older and
bumpy you might want to use sport and
not Sport Plus mode so every driver can
adjust the settings to match his or her
driving style
the GTRs new radiator grille is a nod
back to the Panamericana race car of the
1950s wider front and rear fenders
enhanced traction and provide maximum
grip on tight turns
hidden in the underbody is a new active
aerodynamic profile that's made of light
carbon elements at around 80 kilometers
an hour in race mode it automatically
pulls the car tighter to the road to
change air flow the interior also takes
its inspiration from motorsports
the brawny center console and low-slung
seat position put the driver deep into
the cockpit adding to the racecar feel
manually adjusted AMG performance seats
with nappa leather upholstery our
standard dad says it's a fantastically
fun ride there's no other road model
that's as much fun for a racecar driver
on the track a GTR has everything a
sports star needs down to the throaty
roar of the v8 engine the green mamba
feels just as home on the racetrack as
it does on the street
yeah and some emmanuel says the AMG GT R
makes driving a pleasure it's not quite
as uncompromising as its race car rule
models the gt3 and gt4 but you can take
it out on the road like an ordinary
sedan and enjoy the same level of
comfort mercedes is known for redeeming
phonetic avanti's
[Music]